[MUSIC PLAYING]
LAURENCE MORONEY: So
the first question
that comes out, of
course, is that whenever
you see machine learning or you
hear about machine learning,
it seems to be like
this magic wand.
Your boss says, put machine
learning into your application.
Or if you hear
about startups, they
put machine learning into
their pitch somewhere.
And then suddenly, they
become a viable company.
But what is machine learning?
What is it really all about?
And particularly for
coders, what's machine
learning all about?
Actually, quick show of hands
if any of you are coders.
Yeah, it's I/O. I guess
pretty much all of us,
right, are coders.
I do talks like
this all the time.
And sometimes, I'll ask
how many people are coders,
and three or four hands show up.
So it's fun that we can geek out
and show a lot of code today.
So I wanted to talk about
what machine learning is
from a coding perspective
by picking a scenario.
Can you imagine if you
were writing a game
to play rock,
paper, and scissors?
And you wanted to
write something
so that you could move your
hand as a rock, a paper,
or a scissors.
The computer would
recognize that and be
able to play that with you.
Think about what that would
be like to actually write code
for.
You'd have to pull in
images from the camera,
and you'd have to start looking
at the content of those images.
And how would you
tell the difference
between a rock and a scissors?
Or how would you
tell the difference
between a scissors and a paper?
That would end up
being a lot of code
that you would have
to write, and a lot
of really complicated code.
And not only the
difference in shapes--
think about the
difference in skin tones,
and male hands and female hands,
large hands and small hands,
people with gnarly
knuckles like me,
and people with nice
smooth hands like Karmel.
So how is it that
you would end up
being able to write all
the code to do this?
It'd be really, really
complicated and, ultimately,
not very feasible to write.
And this is where
we start bringing
machine learning into it.
This is a very simple
scenario, but you
can think about there are
many scenarios where it's
really difficult to write
code to do something,
and machine learning
may help in that.
And I always like to think of
machine learning in this way.
Think about traditional
programming.
And in traditional programming,
something that has been
our bread and butter
for many years--
all of us here are coders--
what it is is that we think
about expressing something
and expressing rules in
a programming language,
like Java, or Kotlin,
or Swift, or C++.
And those rules
generally act on data.
And then out of
that, we get answers.
Like in rock, paper, scissors,
the data would be an image.
And my rules would
be all my if-thens
looking at the pixels in that
image to try and determine
if something is a rock,
a paper, or a scissors.
Machine learning then
turns this around.
It flips the axes on this.
And we say, hey, instead
of doing it this way
where it's like we have to
think about all of these rules,
and we have to write and express
all of these rules in code,
what if we could provide
a lot of answers,
and we could label those answers
and then have a machine infer
the rules that maps
one to the other?
So for example, in something
like the rock, paper,
and scissors, we
could say, these
are the pixels for a rock.
And this is what
a rock looks like.
And we could get hundreds
or thousands of images
of people doing a rock--
so we get diverse hands,
diverse skin tones,
those kind of things.
And we say, hey, this is
what a rock looks like.
This is what a paper looks like.
And this is what a
scissors looks like.
And if a computer
can then figure out
the patterns between
these and can be taught
and it can learn what the
patterns is between these,
now, we have machine learning.
Now, we have an
application, and we
have a computer that has
determined these things for us.
So if we take a look
at this diagram again,
and if we look at this
again and we replace
what we've been talking about by
us creating rules, and we say,
OK, this is machine learning,
we're to feed in answers,
we're going to feed in
data, and the machine
is going to infer the rules--
what's that going to
look like at runtime?
How can I then
run an application
that looks like this?
So this is what we're going
to call the training phase.
We've trained what's going
to be called a model on this.
And that model is
basically a neural network.
And I'm going to be talking
a lot about neural networks
in the next few minutes.
But what that neural network
is-- we're going to wrap that.
We're going to
call that a model.
And then at runtime, we're
going to pass in data,
and it's going to give us out
something called predictions.
So for example, if I've
trained it on lots of rocks,
lots of papers, and
lots of scissors,
and then I'm going to hold
my fist up to a webcam,
it's going to get
the data of my fist.
And it's going to
give back what we
like to call a
prediction that'll
be something like, hey, there's
an 80% chance that's a rock.
There's a 10% chance it's
a paper and 10% chance
it's a scissor.
Something like that.
So a lot of the terminology
of machine learning
is a little bit different
from traditional programming.
We're calling it
training, rather than
coding and compiling.
We're calling it inference,
and we're getting
predictions out of inference.
So when you hear us
using terms like that,
that's where it all comes from.
It's pretty similar to stuff
that you've been doing already
with traditional coding.
It's just slightly
different terminology.
So I'm going to
kick off a demo now
where I'm going to train a model
for rock, paper, and scissors.
The demo takes a few
minutes to train,
so I'm just going to kick it
off before I get back to things.
So I'm going to start it here.
And it's starting.
And as it starts to run, I
just want to show something
as it goes through.
So if you can
imagine a computer,
I'm going to give it a whole
bunch of data of rock, paper,
and scissors, and
I'm going to ask
it to see if it can figure
out the rules for rock, paper,
and scissors.
So any one individual
item of data
I give to it, there's
a one in three
chance it gets it
right first time.
If it was purely random,
and I said, what is this,
there's a one in three chance it
would get it correct as a rock.
So as I start
training, that's one
of the things I
want you to see here
is the accuracy that, the
first time through this,
the accuracy was actually--
it was exactly 0.333.
Sometimes, when I run this
demo, it's a little bit more.
But the idea is once
it started training,
it's getting that random.
It's like, OK, I'm just
throwing stuff at random.
I'm making guesses of this.
And it was, like,
one in three right.
As we continue, we'll
see that it's actually
getting more and more accurate.
The second time around,
it's now 53% accurate.
And as it continues, it will
get more and more accurate.
But I'm going to switch
back to the slides
and explain what it's
doing before we get back
to see that finish.
Can we go back to
the slides, please?
OK.
So the code to be able to
write something like this
looks like this.
This is a very
simple piece of code
for creating a neural network.
And what I want you to
focus on, first of all,
are these things that I've
outlined in the red box.
So these are the input to the
neural network and the output
coming from the neural network.
That's why I love talking
about neural networks
at I/O, because
I/O, Input/Output.
And you'll see I'll talk a
lot about inputs and outputs
in this.
So the input to this is
the size of the images.
All of the images
that I'm going to feed
to the neural network of
rocks, papers, and scissors
are 150 square, and they're
a 3-byte color depth.
And that's why you
see 150 by 150 by 3.
And then the output
from this is going
to be three things,
because we're
classifying for three
different things--
a rock, a paper, or a scissors.
So always when you're
looking at a neural network,
those are really the
first things to look at.
What are my inputs?
What are my outputs?
What do they look like?
But then there's
this mysterious thing
in the middle
where we've created
this tf.keras.layers.Dense,
and there's a 512 there.
And a lot of people
wonder, well,
what are those 512 things?
Well, let me try and
explain that visually.
So visually, what's going on
is what those 512 things are
in the center of this diagram--
consider them to
be 512 functions.
And those functions all
have internal variables.
And those internal
variables are just
going to be initialized
with some random states.
But what we want to
do is when we start
passing the pixels from
the images into these,
we want them to
try and figure out
what kind of output,
based on those inputs,
will give me the desired
output at the bottom?
So function 0 is going
to grab all those pixels.
Function 1 is going to
grab all those pixels.
Function 2 is going to
And if those pixels are
the shape of a rock,
then we want the output
of function 0, 1,
and 2 all the way up
to 511 to be outputting
to the box on the left at
the bottom-- to stick a 1
in that box.
And similarly for paper.
If we say, OK, when the
pixels look like this,
we want your outputs of F0,
F1, and F2 to go to this box.
And that's the
process of learning.
So all that's happening--
all that learning
is when we talk about
machine learning,
is setting those internal
variables in those functions
so we get that desired output.
Now, those internal
variables, just
to confuse things
a little bit more,
in machine learning parlance,
tend to be called parameters.
And so for me, as a programmer,
it was hard at first
to understand that.
Because for me,
parameters are something
I pass into a function.
But in this case, when you hear
a machine learning person talk
about parameters,
those are the values
inside those functions
that are going to get set
and going to get
changed as it tries
to learn how I'm going to match
those inputs to those outputs.
So if I go back to
the code and try
to show this again in action--
now, remember, my input shape
that I spoke about earlier on,
the 150 by 150 by 3,
those are the pixels
that I showed in the preview.
I'm simulating them
here with gray boxes,
but those are the
pixels that I showed
in the previous diagrams.
My functions, now, is that dense
layer in the middle, those 512.
So that's 512 functions
randomly initialized
or semi-randomly
initialized that I'm
going to try to train to
match my inputs to my outputs.
And then, of course,
the bottom-- those three
are the three neurons that
are going to be my outputs.
And I've just said the word
neuron for the first time.
But ultimately, when
we talk about neurons
and neural networks,
it's not really anything
to do with the human brain.
It's a very rough
simulation of how
the human brain does things.
And these internal functions
that try and figure
out how to match the
inputs to the outputs,
we call those neurons.
And on my output, those
three at the bottom
are also going to
be neurons too.
And that's what lends the name
"neural networks" to this.
It tends to sound a little
bit mysterious and special
when we call it like that.
But ultimately, just
think about them
as functions with randomly
initialize variables
that, over time,
are going to try
to change the value
of those variables
so that the inputs match
our desired outputs.
So then there's this line,
the model.compile line.
And what's that going to do?
That's a kind of fancy term.
It's not really
doing compilation
where we're turning code
into bytecode as before.
But think about the
two parameters to this.
And these are the
most important part
to learn in machine
learning-- and these
are the loss and the optimizer.
So the idea is the
job of these two
is-- remember,
earlier on, I said
it's going to randomly
initialize all those functions.
And if they're
randomly initialized
and I pass in something
that looks like a rock,
there's a one in
three chance it's
going to get it right as a
rock, or a paper, or scissors.
So what the Loss
function does is
it measures the results of
all the thousands of times
I do that.
It figures out how well
or how badly it did.
And then based on that,
it passes that data
to the other function, which is
called the Optimizer function.
And the Optimizer function
then generates the next guess
where the guess is set to be
the parameters of those 512
little functions,
those 512 neurons.
And if we keep repeating
this, we'll pass our data in.
We'll take a look.
We'll make a guess.
We'll see how well
or how badly we did.
Then based on that,
we'll optimize,
and we'll make another guess.
And we'll repeat,
repeat, repeat,
until our guesses get better,
and better, and better.
And that's what happens
in the model.fit.
Here, you can see I have
model.fit where epochs--
"ee-pocks," "epics," depending
on how you pronounce it--
is 100.
All it's doing is doing
that cycle 100 times.
For every image, take a
look at the parameters.
fit those parameters.
Take a guess.
Measure how good
or how bad you did,
and then repeat and keep going.
And the optimizer
then will make it
better and better and better.
So you can imagine the
first time through,
you're going to get it right
roughly one in three times.
Subsequent times,
it's going to get
closer, and closer, and
closer, and better, and better.
Now, those of us who know
a little bit about images
and image processing
go, OK, that's nice,
but it's a little naive.
I'm just throwing all of
the pixels of the image--
and maybe a lot of these
pixels aren't even set--
into a neural
network and having it
try to figure out from
those pixel values.
Can I do it a little
bit smarter than that?
And the answer to that is, yes.
And one of the ways
that we can do it
a little bit smarter than
that is using something
called convolutions.
Now, convolutions is
a convoluted term,
if you'll excuse the pun.
But the idea behind
convolutions is
if you've ever done any
kind of image processing,
the way you can sharpen
images or soften images
with things like Photoshop,
it's exactly the same thing.
So with a convolution, the
idea is you take a look
at every pixel in the image.
So for example, this
picture of a hand, and I'm
just looking at one of the
pixels on the fingernail.
And so that pixel is value 192
in the box on the left here.
So if you take a look at
every pixel in the image
and you look at its
immediate neighbors,
and then you get something
called a filter, which
is the gray box on the right.
And you multiply out
the value of the pixel
by the corresponding
value in the filter.
And you do that for all
of the pixel's neighbors
to get a new value
for the pixel.
That's what a convolution is.
Now, many of us, if
you've never done this
before, you might be sitting
around thinking, why on earth
would I do that?
Well, the reason for that is
that when finding convolutions
and finding filters,
it becomes really,
really good at extracting
features in an image.
So let me give an example.
So if you look at the
image on the left here
and I apply a filter
like this one,
I will get the
image on the right.
Now, what has happened
here is that the image
on the left, I've thrown away a
lot of the noise in the image.
And I've been able to
detect vertical lines.
So just simply by applying
a filter like this,
vertical lines are surviving
through the multiplication
of the filter.
And then similarly, if I
apply a filter like this one,
horizontal lines survive.
And there are lots
of filters out there
that can be randomly
initialized and that
can be learned that do
things like picking out
items in an image, like
eyes, or ears, or fingers,
or fingernails, and
things like that.
So that's the idea
behind convolutions.
Now, the next thing
is, OK, if I'm
going to be doing
lots of processing
on my image like this, and I'm
going to be doing training,
and I'm going to have to
have hundreds of filters
to try and pick out different
features in my image, that's
going to be a lot of data
that I have to deal with.
And wouldn't it be nice if
I could compress my images?
So compression is
achieved through something
called pooling.
And it's a very,
very simple thing.
Sometimes, it seems
a very complex term
to describe something simple.
But when we talk
about pooling, I'm
going to apply, for example,
a 2 x 2 pool to an image.
And what that's going
to do is it's going
to take the pixels 2 x 2--
like if you look
at my left here,
if I've got 16
simulated pixels--
I'm going to take the top four
in the top left-hand corner.
And of those four, I'm going
to pick the biggest value.
And then the next four on
the top right-hand corner,
of those four, I'll
pick the biggest value,
and so on, and so on.
So what that's going to do
is effectively throw away
75% of my pixels and just keep
the maximums in each of these 2
x 2 little units.
But the impact of that
is really interesting
when we start combining
it with convolutions.
So if you look at the image
that I created earlier
on where I applied the filter
to that image of a person
walking up the stairs,
and then I pool that,
I get the image that's on
the right, which is 1/4
the size of the original image.
But not only is it not
losing any vital information,
it's even enhancing some of
the vital information that
came out of it.
So pooling is your friend when
you start using convolutions
because, if you have 128
filters, for example,
that you apply to
your image, you're
going to have 128
copies of your image.
You're going to have
128 times the data.
And when you're dealing
with thousands of images,
that's going to slow down your
training time really fast.
But pooling, then,
really speeds it up
by shrinking the
size of your image.
So now, when we want to start
learning with a neural network,
now it's a case of, hey,
I've got my image at the top,
I can start applying
convolutions to that.
Like for example, my image
might be a smiley face.
And one convolution will
keep it as a smiley face.
Another one might keep the
circle outline of a head.
Another one might kind
of change the shape
of the head, things like that.
And as I start applying more
and more convolutions to these
and getting smaller and smaller
images, instead of me now
having a big, fat image
that I'm trying to classify,
that I'm trying to pick out
the features of to learn from,
I can have lots of little images
highlighting features in that.
So for example, in
rock, paper, scissors,
my convolutions might show,
in some cases, five fingers,
or four fingers and a thumb.
And I know that that's
going to be a paper.
Or it might show none, and I
know that's going to be a rock.
And it then begins to make the
process of the machine learning
these much, much simpler.
So to show this quickly--
I've been putting QR codes
on these slides, by the way.
So I've open-sourced all the
code that I'm showing here
and we're talking through.
And this is a QR
code to a workbook
where you can train
a rock, paper,
scissors model for yourself.
But once we do convolutions--
and earlier in the slide,
you saw I had multiple
convolutions moving down.
And this is what the code
for that would look like.
I just have a convolution
layer, followed by a pooling.
Another convolution,
followed by a pooling.
followed by a pooling,
et cetera, et cetera.
So the impact of that--
and remember, first of all,
at the top, I have
my input shape,
and I have my
output at the bottom
where the Dense equals 3.
So I'm going to switch
back to the demo
now to see if it's
finished training.
And we can see it.
So we started off
with 33% accuracy.
But as we went
through the epochs--
I just did this one, I
think, for 15 epochs--
it got steadily, and steadily,
and steadily more accurate.
So after 15 loops of doing
this, it's now 96.83% accurate.
So as a result, we can see,
using these techniques,
using convolutions
like this, we've
been actually able to train
something in just a few minutes
to be roughly 97% accurate
at detecting rock, paper,
and scissors.
And if I just take a quick
plot here, we can see this
is a plot of that accuracy-- the
red line showing the accuracy
where we started at roughly 33%.
And we're getting close to 100%.
The blue line is I
have a separate data
set of rock, paper, scissors
that I tested with, just
to see how well it's doing.
And it's pretty close.
I need to do a little bit
of work in tweaking it.
And I can actually try
an example to show you.
So I'm going to upload a file.
I'm going to choose a
file from my computer.
I've nicely named
that file Paper,
so you can guess it's a paper.
And if I open that
and upload that,
it's going to upload that.
And then it's going
to give me an output.
And the output is 1, 0, 0.
So you think, ah,
I got it wrong.
It detected it's a rock.
But actually, my neurons
here, based on the labels,
are in alphabetical order.
So the alphabetical order
would be paper, then rock,
then scissors.
So it actually classified that
correctly by giving me a 1.
So it's actually a paper.
And we can try
another one at random.
I'll choose a file
from my machine.
I'll choose a scissors
and open that and run it.
And again, paper,
rock, scissors,
so we see it actually
classified that correctly.
So this workbook
is online if you
want to download it
and have a play with it
to do classification
yourself and to see
how easy it is for you to train
a neural network to do this.
And then once you
have that model,
you can implement that
model in your applications
and then maybe play rock,
paper, scissors in your apps.
Can we switch back to
the slides, please?
So just to quickly show the
idea of how convolutions really
help you with an image,
this is what that model
looks like when I defined it.
And at the top here, it might
look like a little bit of a bug
at first, if you're
not used to doing this.
But at the top here-- remember,
we said my image is coming
in 150 x 150--
it's actually saying,
hey, I'm going to pass out
an image that's 148 x 148.
Anybody know why?
Is it a bug?
No, it's not a bug.
OK.
So the reason why
is if my filter was
3 x 3, for me to be able to look
at a pixel, I have to throw--
for me to start on
the image, I have
to start one pixel in and one
pixel down in order for it
to have neighbors.
So as a result, I have to
throw away all the pixels
at the top, at the bottom,
and either side of my image.
So I'm losing one
pixel on all sides.
So my 150 x 150
becomes a 148 x 148.
And then when I pool that,
I halved each of the axes.
So it becomes 74 x 74.
Then through the next iteration,
it becomes 36 x 36, then
17 x 17, and then 7 x 7.
So if you think about all
of these 150 squared images
passing through all
of these convolutions
are coming up with lots
of little 7 x 7 things.
And those little 7
x 7 things should
be highlighting a feature--
it might be a fingernail.
It might be a thumb.
It might be a shape of a hand.
And then those features that
come through the convolutions
are then passed into
the neural network
that we saw earlier on to
generate those parameters.
And then from those
parameters, hopefully, it
would make a guess, and
a really accurate guess,
about something being a
rock, a paper, or scissors.
So if you prefer an IDE
instead of using Collab,
you can do that also.
I tend to really like to use
PyCharm for my developments.
Any PyCharm fans
here, out of interest?
Yeah, nice.
A lot of you.
So here's a
screenshot of PyCharm
when I was writing this rock,
paper, scissors thing before I
pasted it over to Collab, where
you can run it from Collab.
So PyCharm is
really, really nice.
And you can do things like
step-by-step debugging.
If we can switch to the
demo machine for a moment.
Now, I'll do a quick
demo of PyCharm
doing step-by-step debugging.
So here, we can see we're
in rock, paper, scissors.
And for example,
if I hit the Debug,
I can even set breakpoints.
So now, I have a
breakpoint on my code.
So I can start taking a
look at what's happening
in my neural network code.
Here, this is where I'm
preloading the data into it.
And I can step
through, and I can
do a lot of debugging
to really make
sure my neural network
is working the way
that I want it to work.
It's one of the
things that I hear
a lot from developers
when they first
get started with
machine learning
is that, this seems
to be your models
are very much a black box.
You have all this Python
code for training a model,
and then you have to do
some rough guesswork.
With TensorFlow
being open-sourced,
I can actually step
into the TensorFlow code
in PyCharm, like I'm
doing here, to see
how the training is going on,
to help me to debug my models.
And Karmel, later,
is also going to show
how something called
TensorBoard can
be used for debugging models.
Can we switch back to
the slides, please?
So with that in mind, we've
gone from really just beginning
to understand what
neural networks are all
about and basic
"Hello, world!" code
to taking a look at how we
can use something called
convolutions.
And they're something that
sounds really complicated
and really difficult. But
once you start using them,
you'll see they're actually
very, very easy to use,
particularly for image
and text classification.
And we saw then how,
in just a few minutes,
we were able to train
a neural network to be
able to recognize rock, paper,
and scissors with 97%, 98%
accuracy.
So that's just getting started.
But now, to show us how to
actually stretch the framework,
and to make it real,
and to do really
cool and
production-quality stuff,
Karmel is going
to share with us.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
KARMEL ALLISON: Hi.
So quick show of hands
for, how many of you
was that totally
new, and now you're
paddling as fast as you can
to keep your head above water?
All right, a fair number of you.
I'm going to go over, now,
some of the tools and features
that TensorFlow has to take
you from when you've actually
got your model to all the
way through production.
Don't worry, there is
no test at the end.
So for those of you who are just
trying to keep up right now,
track these words,
store somewhere
in the back of your head
that this is all available.
For the rest of you where
you've already got a model
and you're looking for more
that you can do with it,
pay attention now.
All right.
So Laurence went through an
image classification problem.
In slides, we love image
classification problems,
because they look
nice on slides.
But maybe your data isn't an
image classification problem.
What if you've got categorical
data or text-based data?
TensorFlow provides
a number of tools
that allow you to take
different data types
and transform them
before loading them
into a machine learning model.
In particular, for
example, here, maybe we've
got some user
clickstreams, right?
And we've got a user ID.
Now, if we fed that directly
into a deep learning model,
our model would expect that
that is real valued and numeric.
And it might think that user
number 125 has some relation
to user 126, even though in
reality, that's not true.
So we need to be able
to take data like this
and transform it into data
that our model can understand.
So how do we do that?
Well, in TensorFlow,
one of the tools
that we use extensively inside
of Google are feature columns.
These are configurations
that allow
you to configure transformations
on incoming data.
So here, you can see we're
taking our categorical column,
user ID, and we're
saying, hey, this
is a categorical column
when we pass in data for it.
And we don't want the model to
use it as a categorical column.
We want to transform this, in
this case, into an embedding,
right?
So you could do a
one-hot representation.
Here, we're going to do an
embedding that actually gets
learned as we train our model.
This embedding and other columns
that you have can then get
directly fed into Keras layers.
So here, we have a
Dense Features layer
that's going to take all
these transformations
and run them when we
pass our data through.
And this feeds directly
downstream into our Keras model
so that when we pass
input data through,
the transformations
happen before we actually
start learning from the data.
And that ensures
that our model is
learning what we want
it to learn, using
real-value numerical data.
And what do you
do with that layer
once you've got
it in your model?
Well, in Keras, we provide
quite a few layers.
Laurence talked you through
convolutional layers,
pooling layers.
Those are some of the
popular ones in image models.
But we've got a
whole host of layers
depending on what
your needs are--
so many that I couldn't fit them
in a single screenshot here.
But there are RNNs,
drop out layers,
batch norm, all sorts
of sampling layers.
So no matter what
type of architecture
you're building, whether
you're building something
for your own small use case
and image classification model,
whatever it is, or the latest
and greatest research model,
there are a number
of built-in layers
that are going to make
that a lot easier for you.
And if you've got a custom
use case that's actually not
represented in
one of the layers,
and maybe you've got
custom algorithms or custom
functionality, one of
the beauties of Keras
is that it makes it
easy to subclass layers
to build in your
own functionality.
Here, we've got a Poincare
normalization layer.
This represents a
Poincare embedding.
This is not provided
out-of-the-box with TensorFlow,
but a community member
has contributed this layer
to the TensorFlow
add-ons repository,
where we provide a number of
custom special use case layers.
It's both useful, if you
need Poincare normalization,
but also a very good example
of how you might write a custom
layer to handle
all of your needs,
if we don't have that
out-of-the-box for you.
Here, you write the call
method, which handles
the forward pass of this layer.
So you can check out the
TensorFlow add-ons repository
for more examples
of layers like this.
In fact, everything in
Keras can be subclassed,
or almost everything.
You've got metrics,
losses, optimizers.
If you need functionality that's
not provided out-of-the-box,
we try to make it easy for you
to build on top of what Keras
already provides, while still
taking advantage of the entire
Keras and TensorFlow ecosystem.
So here, I'm
subclassing a model.
So if I need some custom
forward pass in my model,
I'm able to do that
easily in the call method.
And I can define custom training
loops within my custom model.
This makes it easy to do-- in
this case, a trivial thing,
like multiply by a magic number.
But for a lot of
models where you
need to do something that's
different than the standard fit
loop, you're able to
customize in this way
and still take advantage
of all the tooling
that we provide for Keras.
So one of the problems
with custom models
and more complicated
models is it's
hard to know whether
you're actually
doing what you
think you're doing
and whether your
model is training.
One of the tools we provide
for Keras, and TensorFlow
more broadly, is TensorBoard.
This is a visualization tool.
It's web based, and
it runs a server
that will take in the
data as your model trains
so that you can see real
time, epoch by epoch,
or step by step, how
your model is doing.
Here, you can see accuracy
and loss as the model trains
and converges.
And this allows you to track
your model as you train
and ensure that you're
actually progressing
towards convergence.
And when you're using
Keras, you can also
see that you get the full graph
of the layers that you've used.
You can dig into those and
actually get the op-level graph
in TensorFlow.
And this is really helpful
in debugging, to make sure
that you've correctly
wired your model
and you're actually
building and training
what you think you are training.
In Keras, the way
you add this is
as easy as a few lines of code.
Here, we've got our TensorBoard
callback that we define.
We add that to our
model during training.
And that's going to
write out to the logs,
to disk, a bunch of
different metrics
that then get read in by
the TensorBoard web GUI.
And as an added bonus, you
get built-in performance
profiling with that.
So one of the tabs
in TensorBoard
is going to show you
where all of your ops
are being placed, where you've
got performance bottlenecks.
This is extremely
useful as you begin
to build larger and
more models, because you
will see that performance
during training
can become one of the
bottlenecks in your process.
And you really want
to make that faster.
Speaking of performance,
this is a plot
of how long it takes ResNet-50,
one of the most popular machine
learning models for
image classification,
to train using one GPU.
Don't even ask how long
it takes with one CPU,
because nobody likes
to sit there and wait
until it finishes.
But you can see that
it takes a better
part of a week with one GPU.
One of the beauties
of deep learning
is that it is very
easily parallelizable.
And so what we want to
provide as TensorFlow
are ways to take this training
pipeline and parallelize it.
The way we do that in
TensorFlow 2.0 is we're
providing a series of
distribution strategies.
These are going to make it
very easy for you to take
your existing model code.
Here, we've got a
Keras model that
looks like many of
the others you've
seen throughout this talk.
And we're going to distribute
it over multiple GPUs.
So here, we add the
mirrored strategy.
With these few
lines of code, we're
now able to distribute our
model across multiple GPUs.
These strategies have been
designed from the ground up
to be easy to use and to
scale with lots of different
architectures and to give
you great out-of-the-box
performance.
So what this is actually doing--
here, you can see that with
those few lines of code,
by building our model under the
strategy scope, what we've done
is we've taken the model,
we've copied it across all
of our different devices.
In this picture, let's
say we've got four GPUs.
We copy our model
across those GPUs,
and we shard the input data.
That means that
you're actually going
to be processing the
input in parallel
across each of your
different devices.
And in that way,
you're able to scale
model training approximately
linearly with the number
of devices you have.
So if you've got four GPUs,
you can run approximately four
times faster.
What that ends up
looking like-- on ResNet,
you can see that we
get great scaling.
And just out-of-the-box, what
you're getting with that is
that your variables are getting
mirrored and synced across all
available devices.
Batches are getting prefetched.
All of this goes into
making your models much more
performant during training
time, all without changing code
when you're using Keras.
All right.
And mirrored strategy with multi
GPUs is just the beginning.
As you scale models, as we
do at Google, for example,
you might want to use multiple
nodes and multiple servers,
each of which have
their own set of GPUs.
You can use the multiworker
mirrored strategy
for that, which is going
to take your model,
replicate it across
multiple machines,
all working synchronously
to train your model,
mirroring variables
across all of them.
This allows you to train your
model faster than ever before.
And this API is
still experimental,
as we're developing it.
But in TensorFlow 2.0, you'll be
able to run this out-of-the-box
and get that great performance
across large scale clusters.
All right.
So everything I've
talked about so far
falls under the heading
of training models.
And you will find that
a lot of model builders
only ever think about
the training portion.
But if you've got a
machine learning model
that you're trying to
get into production,
you know that's
only half the story.
There's a whole other
half, which is, well,
how do I take what I've
learned and actually serve
that to customers or to
whoever the end user is, right?
In TensorFlow, the way
we do that is you're
going to have to serialize
your model into a saved model.
This saved model becomes the
serialized format of your model
that then integrates with
the rest of the TensorFlow
ecosystem.
That allows you to deploy
that model into production.
So for example, we've got a
number of different libraries
and utilities that can
take this saved model.
For TensorFlow
Serving, we're going
to be able to take
that model and do
web-based serving requests.
This is what we use at Google
for some of our largest scale
systems.
TensorFlow Lite is for
mobile development.
TensorFlow.js is a
web-native solution
for serving your models.
I'm not going to
have time to go over
all of these in the
next few minutes,
but I will talk about TensorFlow
Serving and TensorFlow Lite
a little bit more.
But first, how do you
actually get to a saved model?
Again, in TensorFlow 2.0,
this is going to be easy
and out-of-the-box where you're
going to take your Keras model,
you call .save.
And this is going to write
out the TensorFlow saved model
format.
This is a serialized
version of your model.
It includes the entire graph,
and all of the variables,
and weights, and everything
that you've learned,
and it writes that out to
disk so that you can take it,
pass it to somebody
else, let's say.
You can load it
back into Python.
You're going to get all of
that Python object state back,
as you can see here.
And you could continue to
train, continue to use that.
You could fine-tune
based on that.
Or you could take that model
and load it into TF Serving.
So TensorFlow Serving responds
to gRPC or REST requests.
It acts as a front end
that takes the requests,
it sends them to your
model for inference.
It's going to get
the result back.
So if you're building a web
app for our rock, paper,
scissors game, you
could take a picture,
send it to your server.
The server is going to ask
the model, hey, what is this?
Send back the answer, based
on what the model found.
And in that way, you get
that full round trip.
TensorFlow Serving is
what we use internally
for many of our largest
machine learning models.
So it's been optimized to
have low latency and high
throughput.
You can check it out
at TensorFlow.org.
There's an entire suite
of production pipelining
and processing
components that we call
TensorFlow Extended, or TFX.
You can learn more about
those at TensorFlow.org,
using that handy dandy
QR code right there.
And maybe you've got a model,
and you've got your web app.
But really, you want
it on a phone, right?
Because the future is mobile.
You want to be able
to take this anywhere.
So TensorFlow Lite
is the library
that we provide for converting
your saved model into a very
tiny, small footprint.
So that can fit on
your mobile device.
It can fit on embedded devices--
Raspberry Pis, Edge TPUs.
We now run these models across
a number of different devices.
The way you do this is you
take that same saved model
from that same model code
that you wrote originally.
You use the TF Lite
converter, which shrinks
the footprint of that model.
And then it can be loaded
directly onto device.
And this allows you to run
on-device, without internet,
without a server in the
background, whatever
your model is.
And you can take
it, take TensorFlow,
wherever you want to be.
Now, we've run through,
really quickly,
from some machine
learning fundamentals,
through building your
first model, all the way
through some of the
tools that TensorFlow
provides for taking those and
deploying those to production.
What do you do now?
Well, there's a
lot more out there.
You can go to google.dev.
You can go to
TensorFlow.org where
we've got a great
number of tutorials.
You can go to GitHub.
This is all open source.
You can see the different
libraries there, ask questions,
send PRs.
We love PRs.
And with that, I'd
like to say, thank you.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
Thank you, very much.
KARMEL ALLISON:
Laurence, back out.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]